Transcriber: Lauren Pepperell
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
مين كان نفسه...
مين كان نفسه إنه هو يسافر ويتحرك
كان عنده أحلام كتير ولكن السن كان مانع
جتلي فرصة في مرة وأنا قاعد مع والدي
قدام التلفزيون
بابص بالصدفة لقيت في حد بيسافر
وبيتحرك بالعجلة وبيعبر قارات
فمن هنا قررت
خلاص الحلم بتاعي اتحقق خلاص
الحلم اللي عمري ما اتخليت عنه
في لحظة من اللحظات
إن أنا أسافر وأتحرك
وأنا صغير
كان نفسي وأتحرك ولكن
العجلة...
يعني صغيرة
ومش هتنفع تسافر ومش هتنفع تتحرك
طب أعمل إيه؟
بدأت إن أنا...
أسافر وأتحرك
في 2014 بالظبط
أول ما شفت فيلم وثائقي مع والدي
على قناة ناشيونال أبو ظبي
حد بيعبر قارات
ليه أنا ما أعملش كده؟
أول حاجة... أول ما بدأت أتحرك
اتحركت من مدينة بسيون بمحافظة الغربية
لطنطا
المسافة بالظبط كانت تلاتين كيلو
تلاتين كيلو دول أخدتهم
من خمس لست ساعات
خمس لست ساعات
وقت كبير جداً
وقت كتير
بعد كده
النهارده باخد المسافة دي
من ساعة لساعة إلا ربع بالظبط
من ساعة لساعة إلا ربع باخد المسافة دي
كل مرة كان الحلم بيكبر عندي
والمسافة بتطول
والوقت بيقل
في ألفين وسبعة عشر عملت team اسمه:
‘هنشوف‬‬‬‬ بلدنا على العجلة’
بعد ما عملت رحلة من بسيون
للقناطر الخيرية
كان معايا تلات أشخاص
ولكن كانوا محترفين‬‬‬‬
سابوني في نص الطريق
لأن أنا إمكانياتي على‬‬ قدي‬‬
ومش قادر أتحرك معاهم
مش قادر أكمل
هم وصلوا القناطر الخيرية‬‬‬‬
وأنا وصلت بعدهم بأربع ساعات
كل ما أسأل المسافة فاضل قد إيه عليها.‬‬‬‬
أي حد يقولي: ’إنت هتسافر بالعجلة
وتتحرك بيها
‘إنت مجنون ارجع’.
حتى في البيت عندي‬‬‬‬ وجيراني وكل أصحابي:
’إيه اللي إنت بتعمله ده
’سفر بالعجلة؟‬‬‬‬
’ما فيش أي حاجة من اللي إنت بتعملها دي
ممكن تعملها′.
بس أنا عندي حلم إن أنا هاسافر
مش بس هالف مصر كلها ده
أنا هـالف العالم كمان
لما أسست فريقي: ‘هنشوف بلدنا على العجلة’
وبدأت على الفيسبوك
أعمل فيديوهات
ده ابني
سلمان ابني
علشان وأنا صغير انحرمت من حاجات كتير جداً
بدأت إن أنا أعلمه
وأخليه‬‬ الشبل...
الحاجات اللي الناس كلها انتقدتني فيها
وقالتلي: ’إنت حد فاشل
’إنت حد بتعمل حاجة مالهاش تلاتين لازمة‬‬‬‬
’إنت مش تقدر توصل إيه اللي إنت بتعمله ده
’سفر بالعجلة؟‬‬
‘يا ابني شوف شغلك وشوف مصلحتك’
شغلي ومصلحتي طبعاً هو أنا أساساً
شغال غير‬‬‬‬ نجار موبيليا
مش فاضي زي ما هم بيقولوا
مش حد تافه‬‬‬‬ زي ما هم بيقولوا
العجلة كانت واحدة من أهم الحاجات
في حياتي اللي خلتني
أطور من شغلي واللي خلتني
إني أوصل لأماكن كتير جداً
خلت‬‬‬‬ ناس كتير تعرفني خلت شغلي يكون‬‬‬‬
على نطاق أوسع وأوسع
ابني النهارده اللي خليته يتحرك معايا
في بعض الأماكن‬‬‬‬
عشان يكون هو يتولى‬‬ المسؤولية
في إن هو يكون سفير لمصر وللعالم كله
دي رحلتي في شرم الشيخ
وصلت من بسيون غربية‬‬‬‬ لشرم الشيخ
والمسافة كانت
خمسمية وسبعين كيلو بالظبط
ورحلة شرم الشيخ أو جنوب‬‬‬‬ سيناء بشكل عام
هي من الرحلات الصعبة جدا‬‬‬‬ً محدش بيعملها
زي ما احنا عارفين أمنياً وكده
لما‬‬‬‬ أسست الفريق بتاعي بدأت إن أنا
آخد تصريحات أمنية من وزارة الشباب والرياضة
وبعض‬‬‬‬ التصريحات من وزارة السياحة
وعندي رسالة‬‬‬‬ ماشي عليها
هي كيفية الترحال داخل
محافظات مصر‬‬‬‬ بأقل التكاليف
وإن أنا أوصل رسالة للعالم‬‬‬‬
إن طرق مصر بتتمتع بالأمن والأمان
عبر الطرق‬‬‬‬ الصحراوية والزراعية
لأن أنا باخيم على الطريق‬‬‬‬
بامشي على طرق صحراوية طرق زراعية
بامشي‬‬‬‬ بالليل وبامشي بالنهار
ولما عملت كتاب
عملت كتاب اسمه الرحالة المصري
وده كان أكبر إنجاز ليا
كتاب الرحالة المصري
بيتكلم عن أهم
نقاط لي‬‬ا‬‬ في حياتي
عن عادات وتقاليد وثقافات مختلفة
سيبك من الناس كلها هتقول لك
إن ده نجاح أو‬‬‬‬ ده فشل
ده فشل إنت كده بتعمل حاجة مالهاش لازمة‬‬
خليك  support system لنفسك
وكمل
علشان‬‬‬‬ توصل للهدف اللي إنت عايز توصله
أهم الإنجازات‬‬ اللي أنا عملتها
لما اتكرمت من وزارة الشباب والرياضة
وتم اختياري كأفضل شخصية رياضية
تخيل وإنت ماشي في قلب الصحراء
كاوتش يطرشق منك
ومامعاكش استبن
الجنزير اتقطع‬‬‬‬ والجشمة انكسرت
وإنت في الصحراء البيضاء‬‬
والصحراء السوداء وجبال الكريستال
أماكن كتيرة‬‬‬‬ إحنا مانعرفهاش في مصر
ودي على طريق الواحات البحرية والفرافرة
لما الحاجات دي تنكسر منك وإنت...
قدامك‬ لسه‬ مية وخمسين كيلو‬‬ محدش هيقفلك‬
اتعلمت العزيمة والإصرار والتحدي من العجلة
خلتني إنسان قوي جداً وعندي
مقدرة إن أنا‬‬‬‬ أوصل للهدف
اللي أنا عايز أوصله
دايما بقول:
’إن‬‬‬‬ عشقي لدراجتي حقق حلم طفولتي
’فقضيت الليل‬‬ والنهار بين الجبال والأغوار
’ورفعت أعلام بلادي على منصات الأمصار
’فأنتِ يا مصر أسمى غايتي ورسالة سلامي
في‬‬‬ ذهابي وعودتي’.
عشان كده
باقول دايماً لكل شخص مننا:
’إذا أردت أن تحصل على أشياء‬‬‬‬
لم تحصل عليها من قبل
‘فعليك أن تفعل أفعال لم تفعلها من قبل’.
كل واحد جوة عنده هدف
بس إزاي تكمله؟
ماتقلدش حد
شوف واعمل أفضل والأفضل والأفضل
السفر بالعجلة بيخليك إنسان مثقف
لأنك إنت بتكون جزء من الطبيعة
اللي بتمر بيها
كل شبر بتمر بيه بتكون جزء منها
مابتكونش مقيد الحركة‬‬‬‬.
دي في سيوة
الرحلة... رحلة سيوة
سيوة أرض فوق ما تتخيلوا من الجمال
اتحركت رحلة سيوة برضه وعملت مسافة
ألف وميتين كيلو
في تمان أيام‬‬‬‬
وبعد كده عملت رحلة لأسوان في ستاشر يوم‬‬‬‬
كانت من أصعب الرحلات
اللي‬‬‬‬ عملتها في حياتي
رحلة أسوان ستاشر يوم على‬‬‬‬ الطريق
باخيم وباكل وباشرب
يعني في نهاية كلامي
أنا عايز أقول للناس
إن مصر جميلة
العجلة خلتني أشوف أماكن كتيرة فيها
مصر مش زي ما كنا بنسمع في الكتاب
وكنا‬‬‬‬ بنقرا في التاريخ
إن هي...
الأهرامات وقلعة محمد علي
مصر فيها أماكن كتيرة جداً
زي ما قلت‬‬‬‬ لحضراتكم
الصحرا البيضا والصحرا السودا
وجبال الكريستال
وعندنا جزر جزيرتين موجودين في الشخلوبة
قرية في سيدي سالم
في أماكن كتيرة جداً
لما عملت ‘هنشوف بلدنا على العجلة’
بقى عندي النهارده 360 فريق مكون من بنات
360 بنت
وعدد أعضاء الجروب عندي
ألفين وسبعمية شخص
النهارده مافيش فريق في مصر اسمه
يعني...
بيكوّن‬‬‬‬ وبيجمع بعض علشان يكون team كبير
لنشر ثقافة‬‬‬‬ ركوب العجلة
النهارده تم اختياري
كأول مصري يشارك باسم مصر‬‬‬‬
في السفارة الدنماركية
علشان نتحرك
ونثبت أركان عجل
وعشان يكون في مصر‬‬‬‬
زي الدنمارك
حارات وطرق مخصصة
ورئيس الجمهورية في الفترة الأخيرة
اعتمدها‬‬‬‬
كمبادرة أساسية: ‘دراجتك صحتك’
اللي كنت اتكلمت فيها في ألفين وتسعتاشر
كل الحاجات دي أنا فخور بنفسي
إن أنا ما استسلمتش للناس في البداية
اللي هم كانوا بيقولوا:
’إنت بتعمل حاجة مالهاش تلاتين لازمة′.
النهارده، ‬كل شخص وأصحابي
اللي كانوا بعدوا عني في‬‬‬‬ الفترة دي
بقوا يفتخروا بيا
بييجوا النهارده لما يشوفوا التليفزيون
والصحافة بتيجي عندي البيت‬‬‬‬
يتكلموا معايا
عشان كده باقولهم: إن أنا شخص متزوج
عندي شغلي اللي هو‬‬‬‬ نجار موبيليا
عندي هوايتي
كل واحد مننا بيكون عنده هواية وعنده مهنة
بس الفرق فين؟
إن إنت تجمع ما‬‬‬‬ بين الهواية وبين المهنة
هوايتك هي ممكن تكون جزء من عملك
لأن هي بتطور وبتخليك إنسان ناجح.
الهواية بتاعتي خلتني كمان
إني في الفترة الأخيرة أفتح store
وأفتح محل توكيلات كبيرة‬‬‬‬ للدراجات
سميتها: ‘المصري bike’
لما‬‬‬‬ عملت store للدراجات
قلت: ‘هاسميه إيه؟’
قلت لازم يكون ليا اسم فسميته المصري bike
عشان يكون ليا اسم
2014 كانت بداية حياتي لما ركبت العجلة
شكراً جداً ليكم.‬‬